I started analyzing paintings as a way
to confront the problem of not engaging
with certain forms of genres of art.
I mean you stand at a museum,
look at a Kandinsky or a monet or Surat,
and wonder what exactly am I supposed to
feel here?
Certain paintings seem particularly
stubborn,
unwilling to move even an inch in your
direction,
leaving you with a massive void to fill
with unanchored interpretation,
but what about paintings that do the
opposite?
Rename a greets.
The treachery of images moves more than
an inch in the direction of the viewer.
It goes all the way.
The painting speaks in a language that
we can understand,
which is to say language itself,
sustain.
Pass on peep.
This is not a pipe.
The painting actually says something.
It engages.
It talks.
So what's it trying to say?
First,
let's talk for a moment about renamer
greed.
One of the most famous and lasting of
the surrealist artists.
A man who never really thought of
himself as a painter,
more a thinker that used images to
express himself once he landed on an
aesthetic style.
It never really changed or evolved
throughout his career.
Well versed in philosophical writing
from Plato to Food Co,
he used that style to investigate ideas.
His program was to confuse,
to evoke mystery,
to show us that what we want is always
behind the thing we see and that the
obstruction can never be removed
completely because it's not in the
object.
It's envisioned and thought itself.
The treachery of images approaches these
themes directly.
The painting at first is obvious in its
message.
It shows an image of a pipe and then
underneath the image it tells or reminds
the viewer that this is not a pipe and
we can infer the rest.
Obviously that's not a pipe.
It's a representation of a pipe and
regret means to show us that
representations are not the real thing.
They only resemble the real thing,
but of course that's common sense.
Who in the world would argue the
opposite position,
but a curious question comes out of
this.
If someone showed you this image and
asked you what it was,
what would you say?
Probably you'd say it's an apple,
right?
Or what about this image?
It's a man or this.
This is a train.
This is a house,
this is a dog.
This is a hand.
This is a pipe.
This little accident of language is not
really an accident at all.
For many hundreds of years,
human beings have supposed that language
and reality had an organic relationship
that the names of things in a way arose
out of the things themselves,
that a tree was in fact a tree that
Kanye West is in fact Kanye west and
that a pipe is really a pipe.
All of that was challenged by the famous
linguist Ferdinand and sauce.
You're an extremely influential figure
who saw that a thing and it's name have
a totally arbitrary relationship that we
don't really know things but only access
their shadow through language in which
everything has a meaning in the context
of the system.
After so many centuries of trusting the
word implicitly,
these insights were hard.
One so hard,
one that marguerite saw that the old
wrongheaded ways of thinking about
language.
We're still hiding in the way we thought
and talked about images.
Realistic painting plays on resemblance
and resemblance suggests a hierarchy
that the image of a pipe resembles that
it points outside language to the thing
in itself.
The falseness of this claim is what
inspired the abstract artists to move
beyond resemblance into a field in which
painting had no reference in reality.
As such,
we agreed on the other hand,
makes this point using the false
premises of resemblance and shatters
them from within.
The visual secret dependence on language
is laid bare in the treachery of images.
Indeed,
that dependence is the treachery of
images.
Here we have an image and a sentence
laid out like a page from a botanical
textbook begging to be connected,
but why should we connect them?
Why should the sentence and the image
refer to one another?
How do we know that the word this points
upward?
Of course we don't know,
but the Pronoun,
the resemblance and the name,
I'll make that connection inevitable and
it's that inevitability that's made real
in every aspect of our lives.
We go about our days confident that
everything we see could be said and that
the images we say it could be seen,
but if you've ever used the phrase you
had to be there,
you know that these are two realities
that do not overlap in the way we act
like they do.
This is not a pipe.
Yes,
but this is not a pipe either.
And if this is not a pipe than the
sentence scrawled in it's cute
schoolboy.
Cursive is actually a contradiction.
The contradiction that pulls the whole
painting apart at the seams and makes it
utter nonsense.
I don't know if Margaret laughed about
that,
but I hope he did because what's more
forceful,
not moving an inch in the direction of
the viewer or moving a question all the
way into the center of the viewer's
mind.
That on the slightest prodding and
examination implodes.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
Boy,
that was,
that was really fun to do.
Um,
I wanted to let you know that there are
only five nerd writer mugs left on my
patrion page.
So if you want to claim one of the last
few,
click anywhere here on the mug or in the
description.
Also,
a lot of people in the last video
commented who didn't live in the US
saying they might also be interested in
a mug.
So if you are,
let me know in comments below so that I
can gauge interest in.
Maybe we can do a whole separate batch
for you guys.
Thank you so much for supporting me on
Patrion guys.
Really it is.
I say this again and again,
but it.
It is what makes this channel possible.
It wouldn't exist.
The nerd writer would not exist without
your help and I am trying to build it up
a little by little.
It's a model for supporting content that
I really believe in.
I mean,
you pay to get the content that you
want.
There's nothing in between you and me.
It's just me and you.
A,
it's a beautiful break.
It's my birthday today.
Actually.
It will be my birthday yesterday,
but it's a beautiful birthday gift from
you guys and I will see you guys next
Wednesday.